[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right uh russell wilson jr iii
we uh talked to him yesterday after the
show
and uh he joined us courtesy of bose and
here's how we started the interview
okay february 9th you join us after the
super bowl
i'm watching the super bowl and i
thought you looked miserable and then i
realized you're probably going wait a
minute why am i not playing
in a super bowl then we had the
interview a couple of days later
february 9th
when you hung up the phone with me that
day
what was the rest of the day like the
reaction to what you said
well the rest of the day you know
started off with i had all the man in
the year uh interviews to do so that's
really
why we had you know the interview with
you and
identified set that up and all that and
and then uh
the rest of the day got interested i
would say the next the next day it got
interesting
or something else but um but anyways i
you know listen i i think that
uh anytime you're not playing you want
to be playing in that game you know this
is why
i've been fortunate to play in it twice
when one of them
you want to get back and and do
everything you can to get back and
that's what our team's trying to do here
and we're excited about the team that we
have and where we're headed so
we got a chance okay wait a minute let's
go back though
that do you hear from man how long does
it take before the seahawks call you
after the interview with me
um uh it was um i don't know
i don't know maybe a couple hours
probably
okay i just so you know i didn't plan on
bringing
this up i sort of stumbled onto it
because
i just wanted to know why you didn't
look like you were having a good time
and then it felt like you you wanted or
welcomed the opportunity to get this off
your chest
is that fair no i mean i know i think
that one thing else
you know like i said we had all the in
the ear stuff that we had to do and
and uh i think more anything else it you
know we just had a
dialogue conversation and i think it
definitely blew out of proportion in
terms of
the moment of what it became um you know
it was a little unfortunate but
i think more anything else you know you
know what i care about i care about
winning you know that's what i want to
do
so i just put my cleats on every day and
and that's always been my focus that's
always been my goal
you know it's to just to win it all and
and continue to do that and try to do
everything we can so
um you know so anyways i it's a it's
been it's been a
great offseason though and my teammates
and i we've
had a lot of great time getting the work
in spending the time together and
we're excited about getting back the
ball and playing you know and fans your
relationship different with the seahawks
i would say it's stronger i think me and
p have gotten even closer and we've
always been
super close so you know pete and that
we've always uh he's always had a great
bond but
i think you know we got to have a great
heart-to-heart and just
you know he's got goals i have goals you
know we want to do great things you know
so
to to actually you know really dive into
those and really talk about
you know you know those those missions
those goals is it was fun so
uh you know and so i think i think you
know me and
me and coach carroll's relationship
stronger than ever and i think that's
that's the best part and about it and
and uh and also my teammates you know
we're we're pumped about the season and
getting back to to playing ball and
snapping the ball and and scoring
touchdowns and winning games
did you ever think you were going to be
traded in the off season
i think that any time in sports there's
a potential being traded you know i
think there's
always a real opportunity to that but um
you know i think that you know i've
always wanted to be in seattle i've
always loved being there and
it's a place that i've always wanted to
play so it's been great
and how glad were you that the aaron
rodgers topic then took over and kind of
put you on the back burner
oh what no when aaron rodgers all that
talk came up
you know they stopped talking about you
and what was going on in seattle is like
everybody was you know then curious
about what was going on with aaron
rodgers
yeah i don't know i don't know what's
going on up there it's not really my
business but
you know you're not following what's
going on with how can you
possibly not follow what's going on with
aaron rodgers i'm not saying
you don't you know watch it obviously
it's interesting it's you know
interesting
in a situation up there but you know
it's i don't i don't have any intel on
that you know what i mean with aaron you
know i think that
you know obviously he's a great player
one of the best ever played the game at
that position you know
you know in disposition so you know
anytime that that's going on it's uh
it's always kind of hectic and confusing
and and uh
you know it it makes it difficult for
everyone but
i think that uh obviously he's been such
a tremendous quarterback throughout his
whole career
russell wilson the seahawks quarterback
joining us on the show
any benefit upside to 17-game regular
season
uh you know i don't know it's kind of
awkward it's kind of weird because
now you got now you have uh eight home
games and
and nine away games um so it's kind of
interesting you know i think that
you know the biggest thing is that you
know nfl will obviously
be able to broadcast a whole nother game
you know the i would say the biggest
you know kind of interesting thing is is
that with the playoffs you know you
don't have that
that extra week if you're a first seed
or second seed or whatever it is
uh i believe that's right so you know i
think that
that's kind of a new new interesting
thing so you know it puts more pressure
on the body
physically the game is such a physical
game you know but
uh you know i i love playing you know so
anytime we get to strap up the cleats
and play
that's my favorite thing so i i don't
mind the 17 thing but
i think it is definitely an interesting
dynamic with the playoffs and all that
that's that's more of a challenge for
sure i wonder about load management russ
for certain players do you think we'll
have that in the nfl
um no i don't think so i don't think
you'll have that now so i mean i think
you
you kind of have that with certain guys
who get injured or dinged up but
for for i think your your your guys who
are healthy
and you know your premier players you
know i'm assuming you're talking about
like the nba out
yeah the whole guys out for this and
yeah so you know like
i don't think that will happen in in in
the nfl
at least at this stage because you know
every game
in the nfl it matters so much it counts
so much against the record and
playoffs you know standings and this and
that right so you know nba they play so
many games you know that
it is a little bit less of a factor it's
kind of like major league baseball right
you play 162 games in 180 plus days or
whatever it is
you know so guys can catch a break for a
second and come back and be stronger the
next day
well football you know i'm playing i'm
playing dinged up i'm playing
beat up you got to do what you got to do
you know and ultimately you want to be
on the field you want to be available
and the guys that can be consistent and
unavailable be professional be ready to
play dominate the game every
every moment they step on the field be a
be a true factor i think
that those are the guys who who are game
changers and true
true factors to the game and and making
a difference and so you need all those
guys you know and
i got a guy like dwayne brown who's you
know one of the best left tackles in the
game
you know he makes a difference when he's
in there for me so i love it when he's
out there blocking for me you know he
you know so you know you always
you always want to have those those guys
you know you got the guy like a dk
metcalf or ty lockett you know
those guys aren't gonna you know sit out
because
another game you know how would you have
done in the home run derby
i wouldn't have done what uh what what
dk did an all-star game
you know but uh i think it was
fun i know that watching trey mancini
hit those home runs
last night was amazing you know alonzo
obviously too
but just thinking about trey mancini you
know having cancer
you know like a year and a couple months
ago
and now being you know once again an
all-star
and being the player that he is and then
being homerun derby coming in second i
mean that's the story
you know that was amazing and uh you
know i i don't know if the sports
world's
you know honoring that enough of what
trey mancini's been able to do
but imagine if i said every five games
you have to play defensive back and play
quarterback
the rest of the time like ohtani pitches
every fifth game
but he's playing every day do you think
you could
you could do double duty like ohtani is
doing
oh man i don't know these receivers are
pretty talented out there man
i used to play i used to play corner
back in the day in high school i was
i was a i was a good corner in high
school but i don't these guys out here
running these routes are pretty
they're pretty spectacular but i you
know what's what the ty's doing
is it's crazy to see you know because
he's not just doing it at you know the
pro level
or you know anything else he's doing at
the highest highest level
possible and he's doing it better than
everybody else too
i mean he's throwing 100 miles an hour
you know 98 miles an hour consistently
wherever he's drawn
and as all the pitches and everything
else striking everybody out but he also
got this
i mean the power that he's hitting the
ball with and
and the poise that he gets it with i
mean he's what's amazing is watching his
stance and how poised he is
you know and and how you know when that
ball comes you know
when the ball is pitched you know he's
you you feel like every swing
is going to be the right swing you know
you feel like he's going to crush it so
it's been amazing watching his success
and another story that needs to be
talked about and told more uh what are
you doing with bows
yeah super pumped um obviously to be
with bose i've been with bose
pretty much my whole career it's been
amazing you know just my relationship
with them because you know as you know
dan
the music is in my family you know
obviously
and we're always jamming out always
listening to music so it's just an
organic you know thing for our family
and our kids constantly moving around
and all
the things we do so well yeah i'm
actually right now
i'm in i'm in texas right now dallas i'm
here for a uh for a bow shoot commercial
and
it's been cool because you know um we
have these new
uh quiet comfort earbuds and uh they're
i'm constantly
on the go as you know so you know i'm
actually using them right now so it's
talking to you so
it's always good to to um you know have
those in my ear as i'm working out
training
i've been training like crazy you know i
have a new trainer tim grove who you
know
um and so we're constantly moving and
shaking and making them
and so it's uh it's one of those things
that it's perfect for me and
i can take any call i can train in them
i can i love hopping on the peloton late
late in the afternoon two at night you
know so i
you know it's just if i have a call and
i throw those throw the
you know the earbuds in my ear so it's
been a great relationship so we're
shooting a commercial today it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be a blast i'm excited
for it
we're at some high school right now and
uh let's shoot this thing so i'm going
back to my high school days
and you know you made no headlines today
so
you're good you're not going to hear
from management you you
you're not going to make sportscenter
today so the old russ is back
the old russell wilson's back no trouble
nothing to see here
just move on yeah yeah man listen man
i'm excited
no i no i it's good i got it the
the old russ is back there's no more
controversy there
uh great to talk to you as always safe
travels and uh
thanks for joining us okay i'll see you
later talk to you soon
russell wilson junior iii